All right, let's do this.
Let's do this call.
Let me hit everyone.
Let's do this and let's rock and roll.
Okay.
So like I said, we've got Michael Steiner, we've got Shelly Xander, we've got Ritu and
everyone else I mentioned before, Stephanie Prather, shout out to Stephanie Prather.
We interviewed her last week on, it was on Thursday night actually, and coming live from
Las Vegas, Nevada, she is at, she just hit $11,900 per month.
So shout out to her.
Pierre, let's get going, bro.
You can hear me still, right?
Yeah.
Okay.
Let's do this thing.
I'm just making sure that I can still see myself and see you.
Ritu says good morning.
So Pierre, we're going to jump right into it yesterday.
We did a little bit of the other stuff.
Maybe I'll just fill everybody in.
So Pierre was somebody who had tried a bunch of different business models.
He was looking for the right one.
He's originally from France and moved to Thailand once, hold on, see how good I am.
You moved there in 2000, the first time in 2018, and then he moved there again in 2023.
But this time he came here and when he moved to Thailand, he's like, dude, I'm doubling
down on rank and rent and I'm going to make this work.
Before you were doing stuff with fitness and all kinds of stuff, making pretty good money,
but you didn't see the scalability.
How close was I on that story?
Decent?
Decent.
I missed some details, but everything I said was correct, right?
I didn't say anything wrong.
I didn't do fitness.
It was business.
I was consulting freelancers to basically find a customer, but sometimes-
Okay.
I thought for some reason, because I remember you told me one time you met Alex Hermosy,
so I always thought you were in the fitness world.
It's my previous business partner that I started the business with, Anthony, that you might
have talked with before.
So yeah, he was quite big in the fitness in France.
Okay, cool.
All right.
Well, dude, I just want to get into this.
So Pierre's at $12,370 per month.
He has one of his deals, he gets paid a flat fee and then he makes commissions on top.
So this month he's probably going to collect between 15 and 20K per month.
But I specifically want to talk about the details of how you've been able to get to
$12,370.
By the way, again, he's also doing this from Thailand.
So any of you that are outside the US that think, oh my gosh, I can't do this because
I don't have an American accent or I'm not from the US, that's a bunch of crap.
That's not true.
It doesn't matter.
One of our other colleagues that's in my group, Mike V, is in Thailand with Pierre.
He's in a different part of Thailand.
Good friends, yeah.
Yeah, but he's crushing it too.
He's at like 40 grand a month and he's actually targeting New Zealand and all of his clients
are in New Zealand.
So let's start there, bro.
Are your clients in France?
Are your clients in US, Thailand?
Where are you targeting?
100% in France right now.
100% French.
Yeah.
That's amazing, dude.
So I'm going to ask you this question because a lot of people when they start talking about
targeting the UK or targeting Australia or targeting somewhere beside the US, you know
what they always say?
Yeah.
It's not going to work.
Well, they say it can work, but they're like business owners don't want to pay very much
and it's hard to convince them.
So tell me about that, dude.
How has that been?
I mean, I've lunch, I think maybe two or three ads in the US.
I had a few leads and I've kind of tried both at the same time and I like it clicked faster
France, but I'm still kind of in between, you know, I might go in the US at some point.
But yeah, I think like it's hard to really judge how it is in the US.
But from what I see, it feels more business friendly, just from the culture and what I
see.
But in France, it's also work.
I would say France is probably harder to get the credit card.
But then people are really, how to say, recurring.
I have almost no children.
I have a guy like his struggle amounts, but overall, like they don't want a child.
And yeah, man, it's like probably harder to get going, but then the trust is very high.
That's amazing.
So he is doing this exactly entirely in France.
So those of you that are in your home country, whether you're in Argentina or whatever the
case is, I'm not saying every country is going to work because, for example, I spent a lot
of time in Sierra Leone.
I can already tell you it's not going to work really well in Sierra Leone because people
don't really search the Internet.
They do a lot of referral stuff.
But there are countries, France, I bet you it would work really well in Belgium.
I bet you it would work well in, of course, in London and Ireland and these different
places.
But so that's interesting.
So let's talk about this.
Before we got on, you told me most of your deals are through pre-selling, through going
and getting the client first.
How has it been running ads in France?
So I started, that's probably one of the few things I've tweaked from your model.
Smart campaign didn't work in France.
So I had to straight go into expert mode and it didn't work so well.
Like actually, my first maybe 12 months was I was launching ads, I had a few leads, I
was closing a deal, then no more leads or like one a week or something.
Then the guy would turn.
Then I would try to improve ads.
Then I would go again to sell and until I figure out how to make enough leads, you know.
So I work on it, work on it.
I was about to stop doing Google ads and go all in in SEO because it was working better.
And Mike really helped me out.
Like honestly, I think it's the best guy I met in this community towards Google ads is
just crushing it.
I don't know if you knew that, but he was doing Google ads like four or five years before
he started, which is why he's super good and exactly in this in Legion.
So then we build up the skills and now we have like dedicated landing page and we kind
of duplicate there.
It's super quick and we have like a list of keywords, negative keywords and everything.
So it's just we are much better at Google ads now and now it's working.
We just launched new ads last week.
There is leads coming in, customers are paying and just speed up everything.
So now we are doing ads all the time, except some smaller sites that are already ranked
and we don't really need to put ads and we just want to keep full profit stuff like that.
But the main strategy is pre-selling for sure.
So for the people on this call that maybe don't know my strategy that I teach or that
I believe in, maybe you can just walk them through.
I know some of the people are going to be like, oh, here we go again because we always
talk about it.
Just in a nutshell, obviously everyone in here knows the regular strategy, right?
Pick a city and niche, rank the website, try to go sell it, right?
Tell everyone what we do with pre-selling.
Yeah, I mean, I think it's not boring, man, because I still work through the whole process
once in a while, like every few months to kind of simplify everything and have everything
in my head.
So I think I did it a couple of times, probably, I don't know, a hundred times now because
I didn't close all the deals.
So it's like, first of all, you do the due diligence, you have a whole part of this in
your program, which I think it's great as well.
Basically, you look for enough volume to get enough leads and not too much competition
so you can rank the site for a good area.
Then you build a prospect list.
Now we have a VA that does this, it's super, super simple.
You get people that do Google Ads.
That's a tweak I made.
So I did a post in an approval with Shiv about that.
Now I SMS people, I don't do call call, I use Shiv strategy.
It's super good, man, honestly, for me, I prefer this because I know how to call call.
I'm not afraid to do it, but it's just, I don't know, it's shitty because you are interrupting
people.
With SMS, they get back to me.
So I SMS like the 10, 15 people that I have in my prospecting list and they either SMS
back.
They're like, who are you?
What do you want?
I can do the job, whatever.
Or they call.
So if they call, I just reply and they call me, you know, so it's switch the frame.
That's cool.
Call calling 100% work is just, I don't know, a bit better for me.
I just prefer it this way.
And then I do your 100% your script, the few questions, like I think there is 10 questions,
like when can you do the quote, when can you do the work, whatever.
I qualify this.
And this, at first, I was quite shy when I started, I was like, I didn't know.
Now I really do this more as an interview, you know, I'm like, okay, man, qualify, why
should I send you my lead, you know, and the frame will switch with experience and doing
it more.
And that makes the deal much easier because the guy is like, yeah, yeah, I have a team,
I can do more business, you know, like, are you sure, man?
Are you working on Saturday?
You know, if I send you a quote tomorrow, can you do it?
Yeah, yeah.
They're trying to sell you, they're trying to sell you though, smart.
And that didn't came straight because I didn't do this industry contractor, they are really
strong frame, like they, I don't know, they are doing heavy stuff all day, so on the phone,
they don't really have time, they don't really care about you, so you really need to understand
how to talk with them.
For me, it took me a month to really figure it out, try again, and I'm still improving
it.
And yeah, after that, I transfer a few leads, with time I transfer less and less and I really
talk, qualify them, qualify them, and then I do the closing call, your script again,
I linked it a bit more with the backend, like now I try to get as many information so then
my team can implement without me doing anything.
That's the main thing.
And then onboarding, usually, I text them a bit, everything's okay, and that's it, man.
So yeah, I love that, dude.
And by the way, I love, this is the thing, guys, is once you have a really good process
that works, you learn it, you do it until you've started to get deals, and then just
like Pyr did, he took my process, he's doing like 90% of it, he did it a few times, then
he realized, hey, I'm gonna make these couple of changes that are, they're not gonna change
the fundamental process, but they're gonna make it a little bit easier, so instead of
cold calling, he's using the text strategy that Shiv's using, everything the same, then
he uses the text strategy, which I love because then they're coming at you, so then the leverage
is with you, right?
So you're not worried about it.
Yeah, so it just completely changes the dynamic.
So guys, yeah, the strategy's really simple.
Instead of waiting for the website to rank, we run ads, right?
You run ads, you run Google ads, and you get leads up front.
You get the leads, you take the leads, you go, you send them to a business owner, you
get them excited, you close the deal, you get the credit card, and then you do everything
that Shiv teaches in this program.
You build the site, you rank the site, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, okay?
One thing I was gonna mention really quick is the reason why I like Google ads.
So I wanna say this.
I actually did a podcast on this yesterday, you guys can check it out on my YouTube channel,
and I put, the title of the podcast was Can You Use Facebook Ads for Rank and Rent, right?
The short answer is yes, you can.
And I want you guys to understand that you can use whatever you want.
The strategy is running paid ads up front to get leads, and sending the leads in advance.
That's the strategy.
The tactic that I use is Google ads.
The reason why I like Google ads over Facebook ads is because there's buyer intent.
That's the biggest, number one biggest reason is there's buyer intent.
What do I mean by that?
If somebody is on Google, they're looking to solve a problem.
Pool deck resurfacing, near me, right?
What are some of the niches you're in, Pierre?
The classic landscaping, concrete, whatever, it's a bit different in France, but honestly,
I was like, if I go to another country, I don't wanna reinvent the niche as well.
I wanna just do the classic one.
I'm probably gonna try some new one, maybe this year, next year, because now we are more
experienced, we have more budget, but at the beginning, I was like, let's just do the basic.
Exactly.
So same thing, concrete, if somebody's on Google and they type in concrete Paris, France,
I know you're not in Paris or from Paris, but concrete Paris, France, they're looking
for concrete, right?
Whereas somebody on Facebook, they're scrolling Facebook, looking at what their friends are
doing and they see a concrete ad, they're not necessarily looking for concrete.
They might schedule an estimate, they might look for pricing, but they're not looking
for concrete.
So if you gave me, if you said you could have 100 Facebook leads or you could have 50 Google
leads, I'll take the Google leads all day, okay?
However, I will tell you that I do know Facebook ads, you can get a lot more for cheaper.
I do know that there's some advantages there, but here's the other reason I like Google
ads, guys, is if you run Google ads in Paris, okay?
I now get to pay Google to put me on page one of Google, so I get to see what would
it be like ranking number one for concrete on Paris without even waiting six months,
right?
If I run Facebook ads, I have no idea what it's like, what kind of leads, how many leads,
I don't have any idea.
You don't get to test the market in the same way you do with Google ads.
But keep in mind, Pierre, you could do anything.
You could do Bing ads.
You could actually, I always joke, you could go and put on your birthday suit and stand
on the corner and twirl a sign that says free concrete estimate.
You can get free leads and use those.
You could get Facebook, you could get leads inside Facebook groups.
You could put up a billboard.
You could go talk to all your neighbors.
It doesn't matter how you get the initial leads, the thing that we do is we send the
leads up front.
By the way, Pierre, do you know what the birthday suit is in English?
No.
Birthday suit means you're naked.
Oh, OK.
So I'm saying, like, it doesn't matter.
You're getting attention.
You take, you go on the corner naked and twirl a sign.
You're probably going to get attention, but you might not get the best leads.
You might get the wrong, you might put up the wrong impression, right?
I would go on an estimate from someone that's naked on a street corner, personally.
You know what I mean?
Some people might.
So depending on the city, you go to that, do that in Vegas, it probably going to work,
it's probably going to work really well.
So I kind of jumped ahead.
So you're just in the basic niches, right?
Yeah, man.
I think, honestly, this business to do what you did, like to make a six-figure year, six-figure
months, I'm not there yet, but I think I can still do the same niche, you know?
Yeah, no, that's my opinion, dude.
It's like, why are we trying to overcomplicate the process?
Like it already, it's proven to work.
So we know concrete works.
Why not use it?
We know that artificial grass works.
Why are we trying to find these crazy, interesting, at least that's my opinion.
I think there's definitely money in that.
But guys, I spent the first like year, I built websites and carpet cleaning, towing, landscaping.
Dude, I had like 20 different niches and guess what?
None of them were really working well.
And then as soon as I said, I'm just going to go in the boring niches, I started making
a lot of money.
No.
Pierre, I got a couple of questions for you.
And by the way, Pierre, they said they can barely hear you, so I need you to just make
your voice loud.
OK.
There you go.
Luis says, what do you think about hiring someone from Fiverr to get a concrete GMB
verified?
Is it for you or for me?
Well, he's asking for himself, but I think his real question is, would you recommend
doing it?
Would you do it?
I personally would not.
Actually, we're trying right now to find some GMB guys, but we are kind of making a world
hiring process.
So we are, I don't think we did Fiverr, it's Jeremy, my right hand, doing this.
But I think we're trying Upwork, Facebook groups, like all of those guys that know GMB
and actually they have some good techniques.
And the thing is, we just pay if the GMB sticks for 10 days, so you don't really take a risk.
But we are going to try a thousand, maybe hundreds to find a few guys that can open
GMB.
We had someone in France, but the system is not working anymore.
So anyway, I don't think Fiverr is the best place.
I think we have now, I don't know, 90, 100 GMB.
And now all of the Gmail accounts are kind of full of GMB.
Like now we need to kind of have a better process.
So we are looking to build a better process.
But I think if you're kind of on the first side, just do it yourself, do it with your
sister phone or your mom, whatever.
That's the best.
Shiva has a very good strategy for this with the Zoom call.
I don't know if you talk about it in your group.
It's like you do a Zoom call with someone, friends, family, whatever.
That is not so far from where you want to open the GMB and you do like a remote control
on Zoom, which you can do.
Then you can control the other person computer and you can open the GMB with their Gmail
account, which is clean and activate because the main problem is that either your Gmail
open 10 GMBs or Google instantly locks you because they know you are not a concrete guy,
which is going to open one and stop.
And also, if you create a new Gmail, Google is going to be like, OK, this is this is creepy.
It's probably some Indian dudes that is doing this in a row.
So you need a clean Gmail that is used by someone.
So just do it with your friends and family.
All of my friends and family had an open GMB in the first year or first two years.
I love that.
So in short, I don't think Fiverr.
I also agree.
I don't think Fiverr is the best place.
I like to use Fiverr if I need like a logo for five bucks for my GMB.
That's like what I use Fiverr for.
You know what I mean?
By the way, it's called Fiverr, but I don't think I've ever used.
I think I've ever bought anything that was only five dollars, ironically.
It's kind of like there's a store in the US called Dollar General, dude.
And nothing's nothing's a dollar.
OK, real quick, we have Stephanie.
Do companies in France pay for ads or are you are you finding people like
and second part of the question, do they usually pay for Google ads,
Yelp ads or Angie's List or the equivalent?
We don't have Yelp and Angie, but actually they are owned by the same guy,
which is worth five billion in the San Francisco Diary of Dealers,
something that on HomeAdvisor, he also on Expedia, Investopedia, Match.com,
so Tinder, Ingen, 45% of the dating app.
And he on HomeAdvisor and he also on Travel.com,
which is the equivalent in France.
He has in Italy, in Europe, like this guy is the king of Legion.
And so it's not HomeAdvisor, Angie's, but it's similar in France.
And yeah, they pay for all of this, actually.
It's exactly the same as the US.
They're going to pay for this and for us as well.
Sometimes they're going to stop what they did to pay us.
Sometimes they are a better deal to pay Angie's or like equivalent in France.
It's 100% the same.
I had also when I started this kind of fear that,
oh, they already pay for something, they're not going to pay for me,
but I think you're 200% right.
If they already pay for the lead, it's much easier to sell them.
100%.
So yeah, guys, if you guys are calling, I don't care if you're pre-selling
or if you're waiting for your website to rank.
Once you start getting leads, you should be talking to people
who are already paying for advertising, right?
Because they're already sold on advertising.
If I had a gym or I was trying to sell gym memberships,
I would be targeting people who went to the gym already
and then trying to get them to my gym.
I wouldn't be trying to convince people who don't believe in the gym
to come to my gym.
I would go target people who are interested in fitness
and already have that bill.
It just makes sense.
So don't just open up Google.
My very first deal, guys, it was a towing site.
Ironically, I sold that website to Shiv.
That's a totally different story.
But that website, as soon as the first lead came in,
I didn't know what I was doing.
I just went to Google and called the very first person that I could find.
And they didn't believe in paying for advertising.
So make sure you guys are targeting people paying for advertising.
Pierre, what's your biggest challenge in this right now, in this business?
So I have a sales background and I've seen your strategy work really well.
So it makes me save a lot of time or just go faster.
So my problem has kind of always been more the generating more leads, you know.
Okay.
Generating more leads, getting enough volume.
Yeah.
Okay.
Inventory, inventory.
Daniel says, how much do you, this is for both of us.
This is for both of us.
You can answer first.
How much do you guys spend on Google Ads per month?
What's your cost per lead?
And how much do you charge the local businesses?
So I'll let you go first and I'll give my answer because you're in France.
I'm in the U.S.
I think we are at 5K a month in ads right now.
But we have some ads that are running and the guys are not paying us yet
because we started the same cycle.
So I would say maybe 12K.
I have maybe 4K of Google Ads.
Also, some guys I could lower it down, but they're referring to business.
They took other sites with me, some kind of supporting them with lead.
So I think we could be around 3K if I wanted to really milk it up.
And once again, SEO is ranking ads are going to go down.
So it's like probably like 30 to 40% for me.
Cost per lead depends on the niche.
I don't think it's really relevant, but in France, like gardening, stuff like that,
it's going to be 20 to 40.
Everything is going to be 100.
But I don't think it's really relevant.
You're just going to see how much you're going to sell them.
And what was the third question?
The second question was, do you know what your cost per lead is or do you track that?
Not clearly, but I just kind of look how much I spend a month,
how many leagues I get, how much I sell it.
Am I making 50% or more?
Yeah, I don't really look either or track it super close.
And then the last question is, what's your average
price that you charge your business owners?
800, but I have some deals that are like 200, some that are like 1,500.
I have some guys that I have like four or five sites with me and they pay me 2,000.
So it's really mixed.
And some it's 200 a month, but it's like organic.
I didn't talk with the guy for the like six, eight months.
I take it, but 2,400 a year.
You put it back in SEO, it's a pretty good return.
Why not?
Yeah, that's really good.
So I'll say real quick.
So Daniel, if we're talking about Google Ads, how much do I spend?
So let me break this down.
To get somebody on the phone to do a Zoom call, I spend between 100
and sometimes up to $400 to get somebody on a Zoom call to close them.
Some of you guys might be thinking that's crazy, but let me tell you.
I make my money back as soon as I close the deal.
Even if I spend $500, right?
You make the $1,000, you say it's $1,000 a month, they pay you the 1,000.
I just made my $400 back.
So guess who actually paid for the ads?
The business owner, not me, right?
So that's the way I look at it.
So that's what it cost me upfront.
And then usually per month, if I do really good at choosing the city and niche,
I only have to spend $10 a day, which is about $300 a month.
But I will go up to $20 a day, up to $600 per month, which some of you guys think is crazy.
By the way, my lowest deals are $1,000 a month typically.
So I'm not going to spend $600 if I'm only making $800.
But if I have a $1,000 deal, I'll spend up to 60%.
And again, what Pierre said, your margins are only going to get bigger, right?
As soon as you get ranking, you're going to be able to lower your ad cost
and you're going to make more money in your pocket.
Makes sense.
So honestly, in my opinion, guys, I think you should have a mix of both.
I think you should have some websites that you're ranking organically.
And there are those really good areas that you found that you're kind of keeping to yourself.
You're adding backlinks, you're adding content, you're doing the rankings little by little,
doing something every day, every week.
I think you should have some of those.
But I think if you guys are not using the strategy of pre-selling with Google Ads,
then I think that you're crazy.
Because you can literally get to the $12,000 mark way faster by doing it.
And you can let other people pay for the ads.
You're not paying for them yourself.
They're paying for the ads.
Makes sense?
And I think also that's important.
But I would say the most important, it gives you trust and confidence in the business.
When you get the strike pumping in, it's very different.
You don't sound the same on the phone, you know?
And there is a huge part about sales.
And sales is like building trust with contractors.
Contractors are getting spammed hardcore.
So you need to build trust with them.
And if you don't trust yourself that there are people paying you every month
and making money with your leads, it's going to be super hard.
For me, it probably happened the same for you, Nick.
But each deal becomes so much faster and faster and easier.
And you're just like, man, you don't take it all good next.
And you call the next guy and you're going again.
And then it's a volume game and you don't really have feelings anymore.
I don't know.
It's so much better.
Once you get the first deal, everything changes, to be honest with you.
OK, here's what I want to do really quick.
I'm going to give away some...
I said yesterday, if people put the word pre-selling on that post,
they would be entered to possibly win some swag.
So here's what I'm going to do.
We've got a couple of comments on here.
Let me go to all comments.
Let's see here.
OK, Shelly Xander said, pre-selling, I'll be on the call tomorrow.
Shelly Xander, if you're live on the call, make a comment, please.
Erwin, are you live?
And Joel Smith, are you live?
By the way, Stephanie Prather, send me a message.
Actually, I'm just going to do it on this call.
You're also a winner because you're at $11,900
and you passed my brother Porter in revenue, which I think is amazing.
Let's see.
So Stephanie, Joel, Erwin, and Shelly, who of you is online right now?
Shelly is live.
Shelly, I'm going to put this right now.
I just need you to go message Ashley De La Rosa.
You'll find her.
She's a friend of mine.
And tell her you won the t-shirt.
She'll send you a promo code and you can just put in the promo code
and it'll send it to your house for free.
So there's Shelly.
Who else is live?
Stephanie, are you still on?
We've got Stephanie.
Stephanie wants her DL hat.
Stephanie, I'm about to place another order of hats.
I don't even think I sell those on the store,
but I'll make sure that as soon as we place an order, I'll get you one.
So you can hold out for that.
Just remind me of that, okay?
Because we've got to get some of those.
And what she's talking about is this hat right here.
The digital landlords hat.
Shelly got it.
Joel's live as well.
Joel, same thing.
Message Ashley.
Tell her you won the t-shirt.
She'll check with me.
I'll see it come through as a notification.
I'll make sure that you actually did that.
Stephanie has the mug, mousepad, t-shirt.
Joel, Shelly, and then there was one more Irwin.
So let's see if Irwin's on as well.
And I'll send it to him.
And then also is Sadie Wilson on?
Sadie Wilson Tangelson.
Sadie, are you on live right now?
And by the way, guys, if you're on right now and you would rather,
we have these mousepads.
We have a coffee mug.
We have AirPods.
We have some other stuff.
You can trade it for that as well.
Don't worry.
So Sadie, if you're on, let me know in the chat.
Pierre, what's your goal by the end of the year?
1.25 per month on December.
10X.
I love that, dude.
Have you been reading that book?
No, but I mean, I read it a while ago, but I get it.
It's quite simple, man.
10X is bigger, easier than 2X because then you kind of think differently than last year.
I mean, to do 2X now, it's so easy because we are already going to make, I don't know,
160, 180 this year without doing anything.
So it's like, just do more, you know?
And if I just do what I did last year, which is like three deals a month,
I'm already at 500K.
So it's when you do the number, actually, I cannot show because we don't have the webcam,
but I have all my numbers here and I can just see what's going on, you know?
For anyone that can't see, which is all of you, he's got a whiteboard right by his desk
and he's got all of his numbers lined out.
I have a notebook I carry with me, same thing.
So Pierre is going to 10X this year.
Guys, I know it sounds crazy when he says 125K per month,
but you have to remember that it's been done, right?
It's been done.
I've done it.
I went from 8,000 to 10,000 per month to 100,000 per month in eight months.
Ryan Dalton, another guy in my group, he's at $100,000 per month.
It's something that's very, very doable.
And the other thing I like, Pierre, is you're doing it in France,
which I think is really interesting.
It makes it kind of completely wide open as well.
Yes or no, because there is less smaller cities.
For me, it's really hard to judge.
Is it better or not to be in France or U.S.?
One very good part about France is since it's smaller,
I have a lot of referral, like 50% of my customers are from word of mouth.
And honestly, I think if I was optimizing for short term,
I would be making more money now,
but I really take care of my customers, oversell them.
As you can see behind me, this is all quotes that my customers sign.
We still have much more to put.
And I really care about my customers making money.
And that pays because then they pay more because they get more leads,
they want more sites, they bring their friends.
So that's part of the strategy.
That's why I think we can scale well this year.
And that's why I really focus more on the inventory and the team
to make sure we have enough leads because I know on the sales part,
I'm not really worried.
It's more about will I get enough leads when I build enough website,
GMB ads and stuff so we get enough leads.
I love that.
Okay.
Stephanie said, and by the way, real quick before I go on,
so just to clarify, Pierre,
you have all your customer testimonials on your wall.
It's not testimonials, it's quotes that they sign.
So if I look at them, it's like, this is one shop in Lyon in France.
It's like 5,000 euros.
And this is some tree service for 8,000 euros.
And like I just, when I'm on the closing call with a customer
and like, oh, I don't know if it's going to work for me.
I do like, I mean, bro, like it worked for all of those guys.
Why not for you?
You know?
I like that.
I like that a lot.
That's interesting.
That's cool.
I saw it on Hormuzi.
He had this in his gym with all of the weight loss transformation before and after.
And I was like, what is it in our industry?
You know, and it's quote, man.
I like that a lot.
That's cool.
Okay, cool.
I've never even thought about that.
It's a good idea.
Stephanie says a year ago, I was selling credit card services,
no money, very hard to sell.
I was selling plasma.
Yeah, that's crazy.
That was a year ago.
Now she's now a year later.
She's at $12,000 a month.
She started rank and rent.
April 1st, 2024 in Shiv's group studied for two months.
I feel like there's another part of the story that's coming.
Is that?
Yeah.
So she started guys, April 1st, 2024 is when she officially started.
Hasn't even been a year in Shiv's group.
And then she joined into digital landlords in July.
I think it was like the last day of June.
So in, let's see, July, August, September, October, November, December,
in seven months, she's got to $12,000 a month, $11,900.
So guys, to kind of wrap this up, I think a good business in this business,
this is the best business model on the internet,
but I think a healthy business should have some ranked,
some organically ranked sites.
You should be running some paid advertising to get deals up front
and you should be going all out.
You should be doubling down on this business.
By the way, Stephanie said her first deal that she got.
So by the way, it took her a minute.
Her first deal she got was November.
So it took her July, August, September, October,
took her four or five months to get her first deal doing this strategy.
And now she's absolutely crushing it.
So guys, appreciate you hopping on the call.
I'm going to drop something if you guys want to check it out.
No pressure at all.
I have two resources for you.
I'll give you one resource and then one other thing.
But if you guys go to rentsimplesites.com,
you guys can learn more about the pre-selling strategy that we actually offer
and that we teach.
It's a quick, it's like seven videos, five minutes long.
You can buzz through it in 30, 40 minutes.
That'll give you a better idea of the overall strategy that we use.
And there's a bunch of people that are in this program
that I also work with inside of Digital Landlords.
So if you see that that's something interesting,
you can follow the steps there and find an application and see if it's a good fit.
But anyway, Pierre, thanks for joining, bro.
When am I going to see you back in Dubai?
When are we going to hang out in Dubai again, dude?
Just before that, highly recommend going on the course, guys.
It was super high return on investment for me.
And I knew how to sell, but it still makes my life so much easier.
I don't know if I would have quit because I was committed,
but it made it, I don't know, smooth enough so that I would step by step stack win.
And now it's so enjoyable to do this.
It's, I don't know, just a super great system and sales recipe.
So I highly recommend it.
I appreciate that.
We just had somebody, this kid that I, I'll say this to end.
I just had this kid that I grew, I went to school with this kid back 10, 15 years ago, right?
Went to high school with him.
He's been watching my posts.
He's been, he's whatever.
He saw my brother that, yeah.
So, so he just joined, his name's Dakota.
And he had a tree, he actually, instead of doing this,
he came out of high school, didn't go to college.
He started of all things.
Guess what he started?
A tree service company, right?
I even tried to sell this guy leads when I first started this.
He didn't want it, whatever.
So he messages me last Friday.
He's like, dude, I'm going to have to get a back operation.
He's like, I might not be able to do tree service.
I should have done this two years ago.
I should have started generating leads.
Anyway, he jumps on the call with us and you know what we asked him?
I always ask people this when they jump on the call to get into my program.
I always ask them, I say, why don't you just do this on your own?
You know, I send it back on them.
Do this.
Why don't you just do it on your own?
And I think that's a good question to ask your business owners, guys.
Why don't you do this on your own?
Because they're going to sell themselves on why they should work with you, right?
So I asked him this question, you know what he said?
He said, if somebody would have told me two years ago to buy a pole saw,
a pole saw is the thing with the pole that has the saw on the end that like extends out.
He's like, if somebody would have told me two years ago to buy a pole saw,
I would have made literally over a hundred thousand dollars.
I just didn't know.
So he's like, he's like, I'm not doing that again.
I'm going to go in and learn from people that are already making the money I want to make
and have them tell me the things to do and not to do.
Because I've already tried to do this on my own in my own business.
And I lost, I missed out on a bunch of money.
So guys, sometimes that's why you guys are in here with Shiv.
And that's the reason I'm in here with Shiv is there's things that he's figured out
that he can teach you in five minutes or in an hour on a video that's going to make you
a hundred thousand dollars or is going to save you a hundred thousand dollars.
So quit trying to do stuff on your own and quit trying to reinvent the wheel.
That's my only advice, but anything you want to add?
Yeah, man.
Talking about Shiv, Shiv is like crazy genius, man.
He was making online money at 13 or 16 or he never talked about this because he's like super humble
and he just focused on helping a student and people in the group, but he's super smart.
And we live in a crazy era where he has this scalability of helping multiple people at the
same time so we can have access to him.
But I think overall, he would just not care.
You know, he would be at other business level, same as you, man.
Like, I think you are one of the guys that had the craziest sales experience door to door.
You cannot transform it online, which makes you super unique.
I mean, for me, I'm super bullish on investing in yourself.
And that's always where I make my best return on investment.
For sure.
I 100% agree with that.
So, well, dude, Pierre, thanks for jumping on, guys.
We apologize.
You couldn't see, you couldn't see here.
For another time.
We'll keep the mystery, man.
Yeah, no, everyone's like, who's this Pierre guy?
Maybe it's just AI.
He isn't a real person, guys.
That's the new AI voice.
Yeah, exactly.
If you guys are on this call right now and you want the actual replay of this,
where you can see both of us and you can see Pierre,
we're going to let the mystery out of the box.
Send me a message on Facebook.
I'll upload this to Vimeo and I'll send you guys a link.
So, Pierre, thanks for jumping on, bro.
Hopefully, I'll see you in Dubai or I'll come to Thailand.
We'll send it again on a Tuesday, you know?
We need to talk still anyway.
Anyway, we'll see you guys next week.
Thanks, bro.